well the world secretary simon hearts
with us now hi mr hart thank you for
joining us on the program this morning
i'm sure you've seen the images on the
front pages of the papers
what we going to do about it i mean it's
it's as you said it just seems to be
completely unbelievable i think you have
to look twice blink twice to be able to
actually fully take in
uh what's happening i think what we've
got to do is as some of the reports have
indicated to keep the pressure on in
every way we can whether that's in the
provision of uh weapons whether it's in
the provision of financial help all of
the different ways in which we can and
have so far intervened we must continue
to do and if anything we need to step
that up sanctions likewise there's a
history sometimes of sanctionings
weakening over a period of time so now
isn't the moment to sit back and say
we've done enough we've provided all the
help we can let's just see what happens
actually now what we need you to step
that up and continue also to do what uh
president zielinski has i think praised
us for doing which is leading the
international response to this so i
think there's a load of other stuff that
we can should and in many cases are
actually okay let's unpack that military
aid what's that what does that look like
well i think we've seen what it looks
like so far it's provided
it's provided well it's providing the
kind of uh defensive weaponry that we
have already done in greater numbers i
have to be careful what i say this is
very much ben wallace in the pm's area
of uh responsibility indeed absolutely
not so i'm not ducking that um and so
it's increasing as far as it is
reasonable to do so um uh all of the aid
that we've so far given all sort of
weaponry so so far given but also making
sure that when when uh ukraine comes to
us says actually we need a slightly
nuanced version we need a different sort
of defensive weapon to make sure if we
can if we physically can we possibly can
we either provide the financial support
or the actual sport to be able to
provide that and i think so far okay you
know we're leading the world in that we
will continue to do so and but it's a as
we've seen
overnight
rather sort of graphically this is a
very fast-changing situation so we are
very much uh watching this on an
hour-by-hour basis okay odessa is a port
that is incredibly important to ukraine
of course there are all sorts of reasons
they're asking for um anti-ship missiles
sunny times reporting yesterday the
prime minister wants to provide them
with that how far along the line are we
with that
well i think we've heard what the pm
said yesterday uh
clearly something we're considering yeah
absolutely i mean he said so he wants to
be able to help as far as that's
concerned uh and and those these are the
judgments which he and others are making
but it's not this is not just the uk
this is about leading a world response
if the response is to be effective it
needs uh the west and many many nations
to come together in that common endeavor
so it is better that we make sure that
we take everybody with us that's what
we're trying to and that is indeed what
president zielinski has praised the uk
for doing which is actually leading this
global
effort okay
we've seen people
with their hands tied behind their back
shot in the head not once not twice many
many many times
quite rightly people are fleeing that 11
000 people want to come or have applied
to come to wales from ukraine will 11
000 people be allowed to come i mean
we and welsh government this is one of
those areas where there is more than one
um
sort of responsible body are determined
uh to live up to our reputation of being
a nation of sanctuary we want to make it
as easy as possible we want to make it
as quick as possible that do need to be
inevitably they do need to be
checks of some i hope limited nature
just to make sure that everybody's safe
in that process but absolutely there
should be no you know
those images that you've just described
ought to remind anybody or everybody
who's looking at this and we haven't got
the time to uh to sort of you know
naval gaze over this we have to get on
with it i think we are doing a i think a
a reasonable job we can always do more
we can always go further we can always
go faster but
letting people in the country so far my
question is will the eleven thousand
ukrainians ten thousand ukrainians who
want to come to
wales be allowed to come yeah i hope so
it's a matter of welsh government as i
say but uh we're working with them very
closely we want that to happen
there shouldn't in a sense be any uh
limits to this we should be responding
to need so why is it taking so long well
this is always i
i would love to be able to i would love
to be able to come here i would love to
be able to come here and and and say
that we can just flick our things and
everything would happen in states i
think most people rather are sometimes
some practical ones who are trying to
keep the bureaucracy to an absolute
minimum
and welsh government let me just say
minister this it's 38 days since ukraine
went to war we know what the russians
are capable of given what happened
in syria we knew even before they went
to war that it was likely that's what
the foreign secretary sat there and told
me time after time so why have we still
only allowed a handful of ukrainians
into the country i think that's
i think that's a bit harsh right we've
already approved 25 000 uh visas i don't
think that's happening
to me that that doesn't seem to be a
handful i think it's we're working we're
working with trying to make sure that as
far as my area of responsibility uh is
wales is as open and available
immediately uh that's already there are
families arriving well we want more we
want to respond to uh to demand and
respond to need cause as i say by the
images that we've seen we don't want to
we're not here to stand in the way of
any of that and just
sit there with a clipboard saying no we
actually want to move heaven and earth
to make sure that we get people into
wales safely
for as long as they need to stay in
order to be already to be safeguarded
how many families are already in wales
well we've committed at the moment uh
we've we've we've got an open-ended
commitment so how many we've got
that's a question you have to ask welsh
government no but you did say that
they've already arrived yeah they have
there are families arriving there are
families in my own constituency i can't
tell you how many across wales this is
an ever-changing picture um and it's a
matter of welsh government to answer
that specific question all i'm saying um
is that we are literally trying to make
sure that everybody who needs to come
everybody who wants to come
can come because
as i said there is no reason there is no
reason at all why we would want to slow
why would we want to switch let's move
on and talk about kobe do if we make
because we have a limited amount of time
this morning um
we're just reading in the papers this
morning that
the office for national statistics i
think it was offstead forgive me saying
that a generation of babies and toddlers
struggling to crawl and communicate as a
result of lockdowns uh enforced by this
government how do you think
history will judge this government when
it comes to young people i think the uh
the covert inquiry will do a number of
things as far as i'm concerned the
sooner it concludes better so i think
what it will show is that some of the
decisions which have been taken over the
last couple of years which people have
been highly critical of have actually
been very sensible decisions in the very
rapidly changing circumstances where we
were learning as we went along and i
think that when we look back and did we
go into lockdown too soon too late what
were the considerations what was the
effect on kids education and life
chances i think that is where we will
learn some uh um
very frank lessons as far as i'm
concerned i think that both welsh
government in my case and or in the case
of wells and uk government in the wider
context i think actually will be judged
better than sometimes uh people give
them credit for because we reacted very
fast to a very rapidly changing
situation we did everything we could at
the time to protect the economy as well
as protecting public health some of
those decisions would have been uh
correct some of those decisions you know
when we look back over two or three
years we may have made differently i
think all of them whether you're mark
drakeford sat in cardiff or whether
you're
you're me sat here uh in westminster all
of those decisions were taken with
public health uh in mind and the
protection of public health if we didn't
get them all right yeah i think the
inquiry
will reveal that
wait for the inquiry um as far as
partygate is concerned of course the
people in charge of those decisions that
you've been illustrating there have
started to receive fines um including
helen mcnamara deputy cabinet secretary
then deputy cabinet secretary
um who was basically in charge of ethics
for the government at the time she had a
karaoke machine in her office it was
used at one of these parties she's
received a fine
karaoke at downing street at the same
time that people were being told they
couldn't sing in church does that sit
comfortably with you no of course it
doesn't sit comfortably with anybody um
and the pm has on numerous occasions
come out and said um how bit how
bitterly he regrets uh the circumstances
which led up to the most of course it
doesn't i don't barely a day goes by
when i don't look back and wish i did
something different when i look back
over two years and look at every
decision i made every judgement i made i
speak the other side look back and think
actually could we've done that
differently could we have done that
better did we no no minister these
people were responsible for policy and
they were partying and being told that
you can't sing in church and they they
were all taking turns on the karaoke
machine yeah i i said you asked me if i
that sat comfortably and i gave you a
very frank answer of course it doesn't
of course it doesn't
why should it
well indeed should the prime minister
resign if he's fined well i i take a
very clear view of this which is based
on well i'll tell you what i have 65 000
constituents in west wales where i
represent and they are not shy and
coming forward and expressing a view
about this a number of other subjects
and
throughout all of this saga of the
downing street parties they have said
one thing very clearly and in a vast
majority is they want contrition and
they want an apology but they don't want
a resignation and i actually think at
the moment the idea given what we
started this conversation talking about
the idea that we might it might be
appropriate to have a sort of six-week
self-indulgent leadership context in the
contest and a little bit frankly i don't
think that's very sensible either as
i've said before we all make uh
judgments which we have time to reflect
on and wish we'd made differently uh i
think for me personally speaking i think
uh the world's moved on at considerable
distance i trust the views of the people
who elected me in
saying that look put this problem right
make sure you apologize you know you
you acted inappropriately at the time uh
and uh but the idea that uh every
politician or indeed every journalist
for that matter who makes a misjudgment
along the way should automatically be
sacked is not something i subscribe to
they do it time and time and time again
well wait and see secretary of state
thank you very much indeed thank you